so well last up today so this is
probably the only talk at the workshop
on layer 2 solutions for blockchains and
this is based on joint work with julia
malleable 'te and Kate Carter Pedro
Moreno Sanchez and mati my thigh so I
mean the basic idea is that I mean
everyone sort of familiar with the
notion that you know there are layer two
solutions out there for blockchains you
know the most popular example of it
being the Lightning Network and there's
the write-in network for etherium so I
mean that that is you know there is some
value at least pedagogical value
definitely to thinking about layer two
solutions as a means to to circumventing
potentially some of the scalability
concerns of permissionless block chains
possibly even permissioned and the
essential idea is to you know if you if
Alice and Bob are performing a bunch of
transactions all the time they can
essentially sort of you know go off the
chain and do their transactions and once
they have done their commitment go back
into the chain and that way I
essentially just do one you know
transaction on the code block chain
itself but the thing here is this you
know most of the times you know they
they may not have enough coins to lock
each channel in this payment channel
network so essentially you create a
payment channel network and if Alice
wants to send something to Bob it
happens to a router that's created
through a payment channel network now
the topology of this payment channel
network graphs is unclear but you know I
do hope that it'll be a strongly
connected network for some definition of
strongly connected and it's going to
allow transactions between any user pair
so this talk is you know specifically
focused on multi-hop you know payments
that you want to perform across the
routing network with a specific focus on
being able to do this without leaking
too much information about the
transaction that's happening what does
this mean well I'll elaborate a little
bit more on it and you know the whole
sort of payment channel network does
have a strong relationship with with
Motors early stuck early in the week
where he presented this atomic swap and
the escrow transaction I personally
happen to think the model of multi-hop
payment channel networks is is a clear
restriction of the model that was
presented earlier in the week during
Morris's talk so the model I'm going to
be talking here about specifically is
that you're going to assume that you
have a black box which does sort of a
max flow algorithm and sort of
determines a path with the sufficient
capacity for you to carry out the
payment between Alice and Bob so this is
given to you you know that's an
independent question in itself which has
a great interest and there's been work
on doing this using landmark routing at
NDS s last year by Petrov annika than
others and what we're essentially trying
to do is implement this multi hop
transaction with what we would call
atomic semantics all or nothing right
either this thing takes place and nobody
in the middle loses money or the entire
transaction is aborted and we're going
to assume that this is sort of a
synchronous channel which basically
means that if I don't get a message in
this time period I know I can safely
assume that the participant is crashed
and I can either about the protocol or
go ahead with the appropriate steps and
in fact this turns out to be like
something fundamentally inherent to this
specific model where you've determined
the path and then you're trying to do
this atomic transaction over it because
it places quite a few restrictions on
even getting to an asynchronous solution
so yeah as a set up payment channel
network enables multi-hop payments so
there's no need for a unique channel
between each pair of users and the
Fallas wants to send a payment to CAD
via this intermediary the question is
how do we do this so there's already a
solution in place in the Lightning
Network for this and the core idea is to
use something known as a hash time lock
contract I'm sure most people are
familiar with this essentially this is
an HDL C or a hash time block contract
you know it says that Alice pays Bob you
know in this case one Bitcoin if and
only if Bob shows some X such that H of
X equal to Y before this time period of
30 days and this 30 days thing is
crucial here so it's
it's it's this is what brings the
synchrony to the protocols that we are
considering so Bob can redeem this
payment only with this valid preimage of
why
so the question is you know when this
has to be done across you know a path
with multiple hops how do we do this
efficiently and ensure all or nothing'
semantics so you know the way hdl-c
right now is defined in the Lightning
Network so Alice would define with Bob
and hdl-c you know with the timeout
value say 30 you know pass this value
along Y with the condition that the
payment can actually be retrieved
only if Bob is able to produce the
preimage that it will eventually be
received from the sender so Alice will
go to Bob the hdl-c is set on that path
between Alice and Bob and then the hdl-c
is set with a smaller timeout value on
the path between Bob and cat and once
cat has received this cat is going to
provide the preimage which was used to
compute this hash and send it back to
Bob and if bob is an honest participant
in this protocol he's going to produce
the Spree image so that he can get back
the payment from Alice so it works
perfectly fine in this setting this is
pretty much a rough model of how the
protocol works within the Lightning
Network so there's one immediate problem
that we can see because you know as you
can see you know this is a well
determine path now if the intermediary
is malicious then the protocol trivially
doesn't have any likeness right so so on
providing the preimage cat sends it back
to Bob and Bob chooses not to
participate in the protocol and the
protocol trivially stalls now the trick
here is that technically this is not
atomic because Bob loses money but what
we are really looking for is that only
the honest intermediaries don't lose
money so if Bob is malicious and if Bob
chooses not to forward the preimage back
to Alice then it's Bob who loses money
there hdl-c between Alice and Bob
trivially x out so alice does not lose
money and cat is already retrieve the
money so you know the protocol and this
is why the timing assumption really
matters in the HVAC protocol as
specifically defined by the Lightning
Network for multi hop channels so every
use in the path sets the outgoing
payment with a time much smaller than
the hdl-c in the incoming payment
channel and as I said the most important
that we're looking for is that the
honest intermediary does not lose money
so if you look at if you think about the
model I mean I don't want to you know
step back on on the talk by Morris but
in you know this model is the clear
restriction of the model that was
presented in the SPO transactions model
so what do we do so what we had you know
as part of this work what we are trying
to do is try to understand the
challenges for implementing atomic
multi-hop transactions and the crucial
thing I'm going to focus on is is
enforcing privacy and I'll sort of
highlight what I mean by this and in the
next slide so what we do is we define an
ideal world functionality for payment
channel networks which precisely
captures these definitions so what we
are really looking for is balance
security which is this big notion of
atomicity as I call it you know where
the honest intermediate users do not
lose value so at the end of this
transaction the intermediate user is
back in the state as though you know he
never participated in this transaction
so quote-unquote in the strictly
stronger condition is serialize ability
or atomicity which is to say that
equivalent to some sequential execution
now why is this important because in
reality Alice Bob cat right now bob has
another payment channel to some other
process you know and and this is an
arbitrary graph topology so they all are
getting transactions concurrently from
you know whatever that outgoing edges
are and so what you want to do is leave
the state of the individual payment
channels in the same state as it would
have been from a sequential run of the
same set of transactions so that's what
we call Sheila is ability and
additionally what we are looking for is
to make sure that you know the the first
thing that you observed in the sort of
the code lightening network protocol is
that the same preimage you know the same
value why this is transferred across the
entire payment hop channel so we want to
get rid of this restriction at a core in
this work and and we essentially
formalized that using these properties
where we say okay the off chain
Byzantine users do not learn any payment
value and you know you cannot receive
the sender receiver pair with high
probability so what does it mean so in
the in the sort of the classic multi-hop
routing
hdl-c protocol that's done in the
Lightning Network it's the same way
which is used across the payment hop so
what the literally the goal of this talk
is to come up with a way to get rid of
this why you know can be can we make the
hdl-c is mutually independent of each
other during this multi-hop protocol so
the goal is to enforce utilizability and
balance security and enforce this
privacy and relationship anonymity
property and of course we want to be
compatible with the current version of
Bitcoin which in our case so you know we
just need to make sure that we
instantiate the hash function which are
256 and I think we're good so the one
core abstraction that we're going to
need in any concurrent multi-hop payment
channel protocol is a to process
consensus abstraction which basically
means that you know UI and UI plus 1
agree on the channel state so that they
can decide which transaction is going to
participate in a given execution because
they're getting transactions from each
of their outdegree nodes and so they
have to reach consensus on you know
which is the transaction that is going
to be participating in a given round
this is trivial to implement to process
consensus between these two nodes so in
our case a protocol is very simple it's
it's it's what we do is at the start of
an N hop transaction the sender will
sample n many independent random strings
you know X 1 2 X n you know and compute
each why I as the result of applying
this hash function to all X J's such
that J is greater than equal to 1 but in
the next or combiner and once we do this
so essentially so for instance it's
going to be for X not you're going to
compute H of X not and you know get why
not and for X 1 you're going to compute
H of X not X or X 1 and get y 1 and the
center is going to provide the receiver
with X naught y naught and the
intermediary with y I plus 1 Y I and X I
and you know and as with the standard
hdl-c model in the Lightning Network the
sender communicates these values to the
intermediaries over an anonymous channel
and starting from the sender each pair
of neighboring nodes UI UI plus 1 is
going to define a standard hdl-c
on this Y I plus 1 the value B and with
the timeout TI you're still going to you
know decrease the timeouts as you go
trust a female channel so what we are
essentially doing is you know making
sure that the release conditions and the
contracts uniformly distributed in the
range of this function each and so that
the HDL sees of a single transaction are
going to be independent from each other
now clearly this idea will work as long
as you can enforce this you can l force
this well-formed notion on you know each
of the intermediate Byzantine users
participating in the protocol and to
solve this we you know what we basically
do is you know company you leverage non
interactive zero knowledge we compute
the proof and we also send that proof
over the anonymous channel to the
intermediaries so that way they can
verify the well for minus of y I plus 1
Y I and X I so it's the same step as I
described before you come you know you
compute the XOR combiner and for along
with each pair X I Y I you send the
corresponding proof to the intermediary
using the receiver
so the center provides the receiver with
x0 y0 and the ight intermediary with
wire plus 1y I and X I and the
intermediaries additionally received as
that K proofs to guarantee that the Y is
well formed but without revealing all of
the excite
so each pair of users is going to
establish UI you know each pair of users
UI UI plus one is going to establish
this hdl-c
so and and you know the whole point of
the proof is that you know each
intermediate user can run the
verification algorithm and if the
verification algorithm rejects the proof
you trivially about the protocol and
there's nothing wrong at this point
because the HT LCS will timeout and
you're going to you know nobody is
losing money you still enforce balance
security you still enforce realizability
no information has been revealed about
any of the intermediate state of the
protocol
so whenever the condition for the so you
know this protocol you know it's
essentially a two-phase protocol with
this multi-hop atomic protocols so
whenever so what at the point where you
reach the sender you know whenever the
condition for the contract un- 1un is
released in the original protocol it was
just why in this protocol un can release
X's such that H of xn is yn and then you
n minus one can release xn minus 1 X or
X n which is the valid contract for you
n minus 2 and u n minus 1 and so this
mechanism is going to propagate all the
way across back that you know back the
other direction in order to in order for
each of the intermediaries to claim back
the payment and as you see you know no
information is revealed about you know
what is the actual hash value which is
being transmitted because each of these
HDL C's are mutually independent so you
know in the more general case you know
so whenever the condition for the
contract UI and UI plus one released so
somebody publishes a string you know
which which satisfies the constraint
that provides you the preimage for that
particular valid contract so if you look
at this trivial example with one
intermediary so you have X naught which
is H of X naught 2 y 0 and H of X 0 X or
X 1 which gives you the value y 1 and
the proofs that are going to be computed
are essentially what you're looking for
which is to check if there exists some X
naught such that H of X naught X or X 1
is y 1 and H of X 0 is y 0
and the soundness of the zero knowledge
proof is essentially going to give us
balance security so that Bob does not
lose any payment value here and it also
guarantees that Bob does not steal any
payments and so as you can see this is a
protocol that is is seemingly very
simple it's compatible with the Bitcoin
script and and it serves a purpose for
enforcing privacy so the protocol that I
presented right now I mean I completely
omitted all the local data structures
that we are maintaining how we are
dealing with concurrency and so on so
I'm you know the point of this talk
which one is checks what I wanted to
stress is to sort of capture this
trade-off between concurrency and
privacy so what is this frayed off so if
you think about it as I said this is a
payment channel network you know each of
these paths in the payment channel are
getting requests from concurrent
transactions with their out degrees and
so you know at any point of time there
are unmolded number of transactions that
they have to process so what is the
liveness property that we are typically
going to get out of these protocols
unfortunately there's no trivial
solution so one thing that you can do is
to say ok I'm gonna block as soon as I
see that there is a channel channel
without sufficient credit or you can
look for something more non blocking
which is to say that ok if you have a
set of transactions which are all
conflicting on a given payment path then
at least one is guaranteed to make
progress in terminate so the question is
can we get non blocking concurrency and
still you know enforce these strong
privacy properties and turns out that
that's tricky because to get some sort
of non blocking solution you know we
have to rely on some global shared State
across the payment channels so in our
case for the protocol that we present we
actually use global transaction
identifier which is given to us as a
black box in order to totally order
these transactions over at some point I
have two payments which are conflicting
on a given payment path in order to
instruct aborting the both of them I
wait and allow the transaction with the
higher transaction identifier in order
to go through and make progress while
aborting only the other one so that's
the non blocking solution that we
present and in fact you know the non
blocking solution I mean so let me just
quick give a quick example of
you know what why the blocking solution
can lead to deadlock so here you have a
payment channel network and I have a
transaction from Alice to Gabriel and a
transaction from Bob to Edward
so because no user has a complete view
of the off gene or transactions in the
peer-to-peer network you know this is
the this is what can happen so you have
a transaction which starts from Alice
goes to Carol and then from Carol it
goes to Edward concurrently at the same
time you have a second transaction a
payment operation which is starting from
Bob going to fab E and from fab you
going to Gabriel and at some point you
know Gabriel is going to this
transaction is going to go over to Carol
and from Edward to fab e now the problem
is you know at some point they have to
conflict on the same payment channel in
order for the other thing to go through
so what do they do at that point so the
currents I mean the most trivial
solution is to just block because you
are in a deadlock situation you're just
gonna block the protocol so a non
blocking protocol in our case what we do
is we maintain queues at each of these
transaction identifiers we check you
know when there is sufficient capacity
available for us to forward it and then
we allow the other transaction to make
progress the transaction with a higher
identifier in syrup aborting both so the
non blocking property essentially is to
say that okay assuming everyone takes
sufficiently many steps and at least one
process will make progress in a finite
run of the system so the intermediate
nodes are going to maintain a current
list of in-flight payments transactions
and a queue of the payments waiting to
be forwarded when sufficient capacity is
available and that's what gives us you
know the true non blocking solution
in which situation now Carol would have
to forward the blue payment to Edward
yeah yeah you're saying there's not
enough funds between yeah and so what
you're going to do is wait and allow
that you know there's not enough funds
for both transactions to go through
right so what you're going to do is wait
and allow the transaction with a higher
identifier to go through and that way
you know the other transaction is
aborted so there's not funds for both to
go through only one can go to say t1 has
a higher yeah I mean t2 here make this
case t2 so we are bought t1 and we allow
t2 to go through which never arrives
I mean I mean we assume that the set of
transaction IDs is totally ordered it's
given to you you can compare any two
transaction IDs this is a synchronous
system assuming everyone makes
sufficient sufficient progress then the
protocol guarantees process that one
transaction runs to completion so you
have to rely on the correctness of the
processes otherwise we can't give any
liveness property so it has to execute
its protocol
so in fact we can do some we can you
know show something stronger we can show
that non-blocking solutions cannot
achieve full unanimity simply because
you cannot you have to keep some shared
state across the payment channels so you
have to keep some global state which is
shared across the payment channels and
this global state leaks information so
you can't you know find a compatible non
blocking protocol while still getting a
very strong notion of privacy and as I
said you know the global I did first
leaked the transaction ID to the
intermediate users and so this trade off
is something that we have to look at and
this some there seems to be something
inherent to the payment channel model
that we are looking at and which is
currently adopted by the Lightning
Network because we first compute the
path we get a deterministic pad between
the sender and receiver and it's just
over this particular pad that we work
with so if you have intermediate
Byzantine users there's no liveness
that's a trivial you know that I mean
that fundamentally follows from the
model and if you're looking for truly
non-blocking solutions then you have to
keep some totally ordered state which is
shared amongst the participants in the
protocol so I just conclude with sort of
some high level overview so as I said
you know the first thing really write
with an HDL see if you're setting a
hdl-c of 24 hours and if the 24 hour
Bob chooses to running from the
transaction then you've essentially
locked all the intermediate coins and
then you know there is no reason for a
payment channel to go to for a
transaction to go through and you know
there's there are several essays on sort
of hdl-c is considered harmful and and
you know what is the real way to get rid
of this one way to get rid of it is to
get rid of the timing assumption that
we're looking for and you know have a
more asynchronous protocol which
leverages failure detectors to somehow
try and understand if if the transaction
just isn't going through because the
users malicious or because there's just
a network delay the other option and
then that you know there's always a
question of like more efficient
solutions there's a solution
specifically for aetherium at nd ss-19
this year which which is which I'm told
is a lot more efficient at least
cryptographically speaking the other
sort of modeling question is to combine
routing with highly concurrent payment
transactions yeah
you'll have to take me through the
specifics of the account balance model a
chance
I believe the NT ss-19 work does it
I haven't looked at it I'm not part of
it
no as far as I know I know any kid can
correct me but I don't know I haven't
looked at it either
if you can but not for the state
transitions like instead of doing a
simple payment which simply [ __ ] nope
imagine it's not fortunate there could
be interesting I did in that spill but
not directly the waves deeper there have
been like like implementations on a
theorem way you can do like like a mixer
over the payments on little for example
on a film like maintaining like the
properties of you mentioned I see it
implemented in the radiant network don't
really like to this construction like
more like modern approaches towards
like doing multiple payments yeah I mean
but speaking of models the other
modeling question as I said is whether
we can combine the process of routing
with the actual transaction payment so
right now as I said you perform you know
the the route computation you determine
if there's enough capacity and then you
try and do the atomic protocol which
obviously has fundamental limitations
because it it places huge restrictions
on the protocol liveness
but I guess more generally you know that
is this question of what is there just
right Goldilocks model for us to work
with for layer 2 solutions
assuming every blockchain going forward
is going to need a layer 2 solution for
layer 2 solutions like they're very very
inherently like
they have done an open surface dock also
from genuinely there like a other
approach like to layer two which have
like there being a group like Jacinto we
have like an aggregator of some sort but
gathers of change runs actions in enmity
root and this like this metal tree
itself can be like a Sahaj style making
tree so like you can have like diversity
in this case and you can have like much
better like capital like efficiency
compared like HDFC based once more like
in the worst case like you have like a
bunch of capital looked up for like so
long I mean so I guess with the agency
based solutions in the synchronous case
and with no failures I would suspect
they're a lot faster than these
solutions it's the only problem is when
you're looking you know when you have
yeah yeah I don't know I don't I don't
have a great answer to why hdl-c the
other way to go forward you're looking a
whole lot of information still through
these timeouts and through despite yeah
I mean you're talking about things like
traffic analysis and sort of an external
adversely being able to find out which
transit yeah that's I mean that is true
right now I mean that the model is
specifically focused on the protocol
implementation itself while abstracting
away time yeah no that is true
any other questions
all right